[Music]
Jack Nicholson's character in One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest brought audiences
inside the world of an old mental
institution and it was filmed in a real
psychiatric hospital just a small number
of those old asylums are still around
today and some of them are now getting a
second chance being repurposed as
apartments hotels and even the new
headquarters for the department of
homeland security one of the most
significant transformations is near the
shore of lake michigan where Kenneth
Craig got an inside look so this is the
third floor I believe this is Ward 18
this would have been immense most
disturbed Ward ray Minervini jr. showed
us what used to be called building 50
it's the massive Center of the old
Traverse City State Hospital nearly a
quarter of a mile from end to end
inside hallways that once held committed
patients are now lined with homes but
each one of these doorways was a 100
square-foot patient room and now they
are condominium cells yeah originally it
was one of more than 250 mental
institutions built across America
between the mid 1800s and early 20th
century and this father and son
developer team are responsible for
bringing it back to life
it was a giant risk it was something
that nobody had ever attempted before
but the idea was that there's an
opportunity here to save an old building
that apparently nobody else was willing
to step up to try to save it Minervini
jr. says his father's vision was to
transform the abandoned institution into
a place where people could work shop eat
and even live and who are these people
what kind of people I think they're
out-of-the-box thinkers I mean if you
say hey I want to move into an old
Asylum you're thinking differently than
the typical person right because they
were able to see the underlying value
and that was going to be preserved and
reused how many photos do you think you
took as part of this project hundreds if
not thousands
Chris Payne is a trained architect
turned photographer who spent six years
visiting 70 institutions in 30 states
they were left abandoned after the
advent of modern medicine and a shift
toward D institutionalization these are
the largest buildings at their time they
dominated the landscape and there was
nothing like them before they were an
American invention his book Asylum
inside the closed world of state mental
hospitals showcases how time Stood Still
when they were emptied out
I saw toothbrushes rooms that had been
left behind as if people just left that
day and never came back
operating theaters movie theaters
bowling alleys sadly most of the places
I photographed are no longer there
when I was working I felt a strong sense
of ownership and proprietorship is
perhaps the final official documentary
the asylums of its time weren't designed
to be frightening
instead the hope was to help heal
patients with their beauty lots of light
open spaces and sprawling grounds a far
cry from the fictionalized versions in
film and TV we see them in movies sort
of all the creepiness but they were
really designed to be something entirely
different right I think the creepiness
comes from the era of architecture and
then when the buildings are shuttered or
closed down the life goes away they
become the perfect backdrop for you know
horror stories and things like that over
the course of 17 years the family
redeveloped more than half of the campus
these like one hundred square foot rooms
have to be made larger for most of our
residential uses but there are still a
handful of buildings that haven't been
touched you actually walk people through
spaces that look like this to try to
convince them that this might be a place
they want to live yeah they had a sign
of waiver that they were entering an
environment with toxic materials and
saying okay now here we are beautiful
building right isn't wouldn't this be a
fantastic place for a homes those people
that didn't run out of the building
screaming were the ones that said they
had a vision and I said I could live
here Susan Krause originally from New
York was one of the first residents
thought it fit my personality I was just
perfect I'd finally found my own did you
have any reservations about
moving into a former asylum no not
really even though I do believe in the
paranormal and I think it's possible
that there are otherworldly creations
out there but no I had none at all and
neither did the team behind the hotel
Henry who reimagined the former Buffalo
State Hospital as a hotel and conference
center in Columbia South Carolina
developers are converting what used to
be a state Asylum into one of the
largest downtown mixed-use real estate
projects in the nation only a fraction
of the original asylums are still
standing today and only a few can see
them the way Susan Krauss can and this
is really special with her own private
spire and a view from the top look at
the view Owen it's decorating just for
us
the Minervini vision that's finally come
to life we had no business doing this
but perseverance and enough people
fighting on our behalf
made it all possible a three-bedroom
condo in that former Asylum recently
sold for nearly $800,000 and if you're
not quite ready to move in they do offer
tours and people are very very curious
so far this year 19,000 people have gone
there though I don't know if I can do it
I think the horror films got to me but
those spaces are and when you go there
you feel the weight you feel the history
and the grounds are stunning on their
own great way to flip some property yeah
and it's hard work lieutenant Thanks